♪ [music] ♪
Expanding on the notion of stable growth
and terminal value. Now let's fill in the
rest of the details and what happens to
your company when it becomes a
mature company. After all,
when you make your company a
mature company, not only should the growth
rate change but so should every other
characteristic of the company.
Before we look at the other components
of a mature company,
I'm going to try to value Valley.
Because if I've decided to make Valley a
mature company, then the valuation becomes
very simple, right? I don't have to
estimate cash flows for a growth period,
I don't have to estimate a growth period,
I can do the valuation as of right now.
To make my best estimates for Valley,
rather than use the most recent
years' numbers, which is always dangerous
for a commodity company,
I try to normalize. Normalize in what
sense? I looked at the last five years
leading into my valuation,
and over those five years here's what
I saw. I saw an average operating income
of 17.6 billion, an average effective tax
rate of 20.92%, and an average return on
capital of 17.25%. I'm going to assume
that those are the numbers that Valley
will return to overtime.
It's an assumption, but I think it's a
fairly solid assumption for a
commodity company. So let's talk about the
cost of capital for Valley.
To estimate the cost of capital for
Valley, I looked at the businesses it
was in, and took a weighted average paid
at the bottom of beta.
I took into account how much debt Valley
uses in its operations,
and where it does business to get its
equity risk premium.
The composite value that I get is 8.2% as
my cost of capital, and I'm doing the cost
of capital in U.S. dollar terms because my
cash flows are in U.S. dollars.
I'm almost there. To make my valuation of
Valley work, I took the return on capital
of 17.25% as my steady state return on
capital. I used a growth rate of 2%
in perpetuity, less than the risk free
rate, and that gave me a reinvestment rate
of about 11.59%, that's a growth rate
divided by the return on capital.
And my value for Valley reflects my
normalized numbers. I start with the
normalized operating income,
$17,626 million. I net out the tax rate
based on my normalized tax rate of 20.92%.
I net out my reinvestment of 11.59% based
on my normalized numbers.
And I discount that back at 8.2%,
allowing for a 2% growth rate in
perpetuity. The value that I get for the
operating assets at Valley is $203
billion. I add cash, I subtract our debt,
I get a value for the equity of $167
billion. These assumptions lead me to a
value per share of $32.44.
Divided by the number of shares,
the value per share that I get for Valley
is $13.57. Now let me back up,
did I make a lot of assumptions in this
valuation?
Absolutely. I'm I assuming that Valley is
a mature company?
Absolutely. The value per share that I get
for Valley is $32.44,
well above the stock price of $13.57.
So now that we've got the Valley valuation
behind us, as a mature company let's turn
to two other rules I want to introduce
into your terminal value calculation.
The first is, remember in the context
of growth I talked about the value of
growth being a function of excess returns?
I'm going to revisit that question now
that you've told me your company is going
to become a mature company.
I'm going to ask you,
what kind of excess returns do you think
your company will make as a
mature company? Your answers can range
from, it will not make excess returns,
it will make very large excess returns.
Note though, that as your company becomes
mature those excess returns will probably
become lower as competition enters.
But here's why I need to know what your
excess returns are. To estimate what you
will need to reinvest in perpetuity,
I need to know what return in capital you
will make in perpetuity.
So let's put some numbers.
Let's assume you tell me your company will
have a 2% growth rate,
and that you think your return on capital
will be 10%. Those are the numbers
incidentally that I assumed for Disney.
To grow at 2% with a 10% return
on capital, you will need to reinvest
about 20% each year forever.
Growth has to be earned,
and you cannot violate that rule just
because you're looking at a mature
company. Now the big question
then becomes, do mature companies earn
more than their cost of capital?
There are some who argue no.
In fact, there are some discounted cash
flow valuations with the excess returns
for mature companies are always set to
zero. If you set your return on capital
equal to your cost of capital,
you know what the value of your growth is
going to be? It's going to be zero.
You might as well use a zero growth rate
in perpetuity if that is the case.
But do companies actually earn their cost
of capital once they become
mature companies? There is some evidence
that suggests that companies continue
to earn excess returns for far longer than
they maintain growth. Put differently,
there are lots of mature companies
out there that earn more than their cost
of capital. So leave that door open,
that if you have a special company,
a company with unique competitive
advantages, it might be able to earn more
than its cost of capital.
There's a final point I want to make
about terminal value calculations
is, when you put your company to stable
growth, give it the characteristics of a
stable growth company. Put differently,
when you make your company a mature
company, you're going to bring its growth
rate down, right? That's bad.
But there's some good stuff that happens
when you become a mature company.
Your cost of capital will have to become
that of a mature company.
So if you're valuing a young,
high growth company,
your cost of capital to start the process
might be 12%, 14%, or 15% but in stable
growth, I would expect that cost
of capital converge on the cost of capital
of a mature company.
If you're using betas,
for a high growth company your beta could
be 2, 2.5 or even 3.
But for a mature company,
that number can't be that different from
1. In fact, I have a very simple rule
of thumb, since two thirds of all
companies have betas between 0.8 and 1.2,
I'm going to put a mature company in that
range. So when I'm looking at a mature
company valuation, I would
expect the beta to be closer to 1.
I would also expect mature companies to be
able to borrow more money and have returns
in capital that are closer to the cost of
capital. In effect, when you give me the
characteristics of your company 10 years
from now as a mature company,
don't just reproduce the characteristics
you have for that company today.
So your terminal value calculation should
reflect your characteristics of the
company as a mature company.
Now as I look at discounted cash
flow valuations, I'm often struck by
inconsistent assumptions especially when
it comes to the terminal value.
Let me give you one very common example.
Let's assume you're looking at a
discounted cash flow valuation. When
you're 10, your company becomes a mature
company. It's given a growth rate of 2%
a year, a defensible number.
But then the analysts says,
"This is a mature company,
therefore I'm going to assume that CapEx
offsets depreciation.
It does not need net CapEx,
and it does not need working capital,
change in working capital is zero."
That is a valuation that's internally
inconsistent, and here's why.
If you're net CapEx is zero,
and your change in working capital
is zero, you're reinvesting nothing,
right? Your reinvestment rate is zero.
And since your growth rate is your
reinvestment rate times your return
on capital, you cannot grow 2% a year
forever. Now, the comeback you might get
from some analysts is that the growth rate
is just the inflation rate,
and therefore you don't have to build new
capacity. That might be true,
but you have to replace old capacity,
right? And if you have inflation helping
you on your revenues,
it's going to hurt you when you
replace old equipment, old machinery.
There is no way around the reality,
that if you're going to grow your company
you will have to reinvest to sustain
that growth. So let me summarize.
When you look at your terminal value,
you want to put a growth cap,
you want to make sure you don't wait
too long, you want to make sure you
reinvest enough to sustain your stable
growth rate, and that you give your
company the characteristics of a
mature company. So let me try these very
simple principles on Disney.
I'm going to make Disney a mature company
after year 10. I'm going to give it a
growth rate of 2.5%,
that's less than the risk free rates
so I'm obeying the cap.
To estimate how much Disney will have
to reinvest in stable growth,
I'm going to assume that Disney's return
on capital once it becomes a mature
company is 10%. That's lower than the
12.61% it's earning now,
but it's higher than its cost of capital.
I'll back it up by arguing that Disney's
competitive advantages are so strong and
so sustainable that they will not
disappear in year 11.
Now that return on capital of 10% in
conjunction with my 2.5% growth rate gives
me a reinvestment rate of 25%.
That's what you're going to see as my
reinvestment rate in year 11. Finally,
I make Disney a mature company not just
in its growth rate but in its cost of
capital. I give it the benefit of having a
lower cost to capital as a mature company,
a cost of capital of 7.29% instead of the
7.81% you see now. In year 10,
Disney is a mature company meeting all
of my constraints. If you're doing a
discounted cash flow valuation for the
first time, the terminal value scares you,
right? And it should. It's a big number.
But if you follow the rules I've suggested
you should in this session,
you're going to be okay,
you're going to be able to keep the
terminal value under your control.
And here are the rules again:
check your growth rate,
make sure it's less than your risk free
rate which is my proxy for nominal growth
in the economy. Or if you want to estimate
the nominal growth in the economy, make
sure it's less than that number.
Second, don't wait too long to make your
company a mature company.
Third, make sure you're reinvesting enough
to sustain your stable growth rate.
And finally, give your company the
characteristics of a mature company.
It's not just the growth rate that changes
when you become a mature company,
it's everything else about the company.
And if you do all of those things,
your terminal value will be your number to
control rather than the other way around.
♪ [music] ♪